this saturday uh floyd mayweather and
conor mcgregor are gonna fight each
other in las vegas that's a big deal
yeah
a lot of people are excited about this
matchup uh andy i haven't asked you do
you have any thoughts about the mcgregor
mayweather fight well i'm nothing clever
original or perceptive but uh i can
spout empty meaningless sports cliches
wait a minute empty meaningless sports
cliches andy are you proposing that we
have a good old-fashioned sports cliche
battle
that's exactly what i'm proposing all
right
let's do this let's bring up the cliche
counter
the topic is the mayweather mcgregor
fight this saturday andy what are your
thoughts well conor mcgregor can talk
the talk but can he walk the walk i
agree he's gonna have to put his money
where his mouth is
that's right it's time to see if his
bark is worse than his bite because at
the end of the day actions speak louder
than words
i agree andy it's not the size of the
dog in the fight it's the size of the
fight in the dog but floyd mayweather is
no spring chicken it's going to come
down to who wants it more
and we'll see what happens when the
rubber meets the road but if conor hits
the ground running this could be one for
the ages
uh
i don't know conan i mean
conor can hit but a good boxer always
beats a good puncher mcgregor may be
tough as nails but the proof is in the
pudding
don't get me wrong mcgregor's rising up
straight to the top got the guts got the
glory
went the distance now he's not going to
stop just a man and his will to survive
it's the eye of the tiger
it's the it's the thrill of the fight
rising up to the challenge of his rival
and the last known survivor stalks his
prey in the night and he's watching us
all with the eye
say it with me
[Applause]
good job andy
your papers have nothing written i'm a
newsman